wegen der frage wohin ich komme ich aus
diesem dieser vorstellung vor wie ich
mit dreadlocks aussehen würde
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge marienhof
ich bin heute alleine weil ich eine
letzte folge gestorben bin ich wollte
mir eigentlich den max kran crafter
packen und mit ihm eine folge aufnehmen
wo wir über themen quatschen weil ich
die nächste folge dir morgen sehen
werdet werde ich mit cap aufnehmen
bei cap wohl irgendwie was hat wo man
zurück zum sport wo man irgendwie wo ich
zurück zu statt blau komme dass er
morgen wieder an statt blau ich mal hier
kurzem weg punkt weil hier dieses
aluminium ich glaube das ist aluminium
deswegen mama ganz kurz hallo herr komme
ich hatte mit lucia nach er wieder nur
damit ich da eventuell nachher noch mal
hingehen wenn ich diamanten finden
sollte und zwar
hat es irgendwie so ein portal aufgebaut
mit dem ich von spawn vom nullpunkt
zurück in die unterrichtet kennt sagt
dass nur das ist am nullpunkt es ist
nicht so ein weiter weg also ich muß ca
200 laufen weit her ist jetzt auch nicht
so weit kann man schon machen und ich
musste mich jetzt hier halt so ein
bisschen drauf vorbereiten auf das leben
in der wildnis diese eine folge wo ich
jetzt hier bin deswegen wollte ich
eigentlich dass der max mit dabei ist
dass wir so ein paar themen bei twitter
durchgehend unter dem hashtag ccp habe
ich einfach mal gemacht unter dem namen
einer partei eine hand und da sind auch
wieder ein paar chillige themen
angekommen über die ich dann jeden
moment reden werde während ich hier
erstmal mir die nötigsten sachen
zusammen kräfte und war
worauf ich erstmal stöcker mein gott es
ist wieder wie am start so erstmal eine
spitzhacke jetzt noch ein
wer hat dich nämlich auch mal mit und
zwar sind hier richtig richtig richtig
viele thema gekommen weil ihnen die alle
zeugnisse bekommen haben nehme ich erst
mal das thema von nils peters wenn du
heute ebenfalls zeugnis bekommen hast
ist es eher gute da eher schlecht weiß
schneidhain
ich finde eigentlich dass mein zeugnis
in ordnung ist die eltern denken
natürlich immer so natürlich genial
richtig weg hey hast du eventuell ein
portal vom nullpunkt zu statt blau
naja ich brauche auf jeden fall mehr zu
fressen ja mein zeugnis an sich also ich
bin ja in der oberstufe das ist ja so
die meisten von euch werden
wahrscheinlich so noten bekommen wie
1234 blabla aber nicht dass hier 500
wechsel steht da nicht sowieso ein zu
statt gelb und von gelb zu blau
ich muss mal gucken aber glaube nicht
herr berlin entsteht dann wäre chillig
ich habe bisher noch keines gesehen
das fängt hier und jetzt was das findet
ihr ein schwarzer bär und zwar habe ich
einen schnitt von also ich bekomme ja
punkte in der oberstufe da ist dann zum
beispiel damit man das besser
differenzieren kann bei mir ist es zum
beispiel so dass eine 3 zum beispiel
sind acht punkte
eine 2 sind elf punkte und eine eins in
14 punkte und ich habe zwei einsen in
sport und religion
killer ok muss sich wohl doch nicht mit
cap dahin
ich möchte zwar mit einem schneeball
werfen wo mein gott schon einen
schneeball treffe ich wohl knapp noch
mal mein abo können wir das portal
kräftiger jetzt bin ich hier
hierdurch freshman danke das ist nicht
okay ich will wieder zurück statt blau
und ich denke sogar dass ich alle meine
sache noch habe ich halte ich will so
richtig schön ich themen vorbereitet
aber ich wusste gar nicht dass zu werfen
weil ich dachte zuhörer die stars alter
das egal da man ja direkt zurück ok du
dich also ich finde an sich das halo hat
nicht hier irgendwie
gut ich gehe dann einfach mal woanders
rain oh ha wie viele bäume da gewachsen
wo ich die gepflanzt habe oha das ist ja
alles zugewuchert hier wie geil ist das
denn
kann man nicht den abenteuerpark braune
ja ja ich finde an sich mal zeugnis ist
eigentlich gut aber es ist halt dann
immer so die rhodo beobachtet durch
erzählt immer ansichtssache
wenn dann herzen streber sieht er dachte
natürlich denke ich mir auch da hätte
ich besser sein können aber ja weil sie
nicht ich bin halt an sich zufrieden
damit zum abi hin werde ich versuchen
das ganze nochmal besser hin zu
klatschen durch robert berlin glöckchen
comics wenig direkt irgendwo
hinschmeißen wohl nicht wert von ich
einfach dahin ist nicht noch aluminium
von mir drin
ja klar bin ich ob hopp hopp hopp hopp
hopp hopp hopp hopp hopp
so ihr kommt auch noch an so und die
ersten fahrer musste ich mich dann auch
noch mal ein bisschen kümmern aber ich
nehme es erstmal eine ganze sachen und
geht zurück zum spawn meine rüstungs
auch schon dreimal erst mal zurück zum
spawn weil dort dominiert wurde markiert
so wartet da dem bogen
denn die spitzhacke da kann man
eigentlich fackeln hin da sind fackeln
und die wohl auch gar nicht so
dementsprechend ich gehe jetzt erstmal
warten zurück zu warten dass andere
portal wo bin ich denn da zucker her
gekommen da war das doch irgendwo da
hier das ist extra sein fett ab hallo
hallo
so jetzt muss ich noch mal hier durch
ich glaube hier war das crash so und
jetzt da müsste aluminium sein okay da
müsste kämpfen jetzt noch gar nicht
helfen
danke zamba auf jeden fall an dieser
stelle danke herr dich zum bäcker dem
alle zu ihm gehen und ihm einen
runterholen
also kann ich das denn jetzt hier
irgendwie abbauen ja das aluminium
gravel juhu eventuell können wir uns in
dieser folge noch ein tolles herz bauer
nur hey freut euch alle mit mir und das
hier ist also das freundlich hatte ich
jetzt nicht den waypoint ihr irgendwie
options auch ja keiner aufschreiben
immer wie ich nie wieder krieg
ich könnte auch mal einfach mit meiner
leistung hier hingehen nochmal zum
nullpunkt und dann einfach hier nochmal
ich hoffe dass es mit ich hab gar kein
zu essen mit der e mails auf ok aber
jetzt noch was zu fressen vip club
zurück zur stadt blau
hallo statt blau guten tag so aber wir
wollen uns natürlich hier nicht beirren
lassen wir natürlich noch eine frage
würdest du dir dreck dreadlocks machen
das ist eine heftige frage an sich
erstmal nicht weil ich eigentlich nichts
gegen die leute mit dreadlocks oder
simon in diesem fall auf den die frage
wahrscheinlich bezogen ist ich bin ein
typ der gern so kontrollen seinen haaren
hat sagen ich meine jetzt nicht dass man
mit dreadlocks keine kontrolle etwas
wenn wir auf jeden fall zu wenig
kontrolle
wenn ich so viele haare auf kopf hätten
auch immer so heiß und so ich mag halt
meine frisur so an sich wie sie es finde
ich glaub ich sogar zu gelangen
also wenn ihr die folge gerade seht dann
war ich heute schon beim friseur war 13
uhr die volk muss halt noch online ihr
wisst mein internet dies dass ich lass
mir zeit sagt sich mein internet da wart
mal da kenne ich noch aluminium irgendwo
warum habe ich das ewo weggesteckt
weggesteckt
aluminium ist nix drin ich habe das in
der denksport rennen gehabt da nichts
dran
ich hab nur zwei extra herzen bisher
relativ wenig von aluminium ag dabei was
ich damit machen kann weil ja auch nicht
nix da
drei aluminium das auch noch zwei mini
miniatur herr arthur noch irgendwo wird
witzig das einfach überall meine kisten
verteilt stehen hier bei dieser
baustelle so übrigens habe ich meine
meinung bezüglich des übergriffs auch
nochmal aluminium nicht geändert ich
finde es immer noch pussy mäßig bräuchte
noch so aber während der den sucht kann
ich eigentlich schon mal so machen und
diese komischen komischen tanz also
packe ich erstmal dahin rein weil jetzt
die frage ja dreadlocks weit ich habe
geld kontrolle meinen haaren und wenn
ich jetzt auch gerade dieses video wenn
ihr das gerade seht war ich schon beim
friseur hat wahrscheinlich schon bei
instagram dot com / laser luca folgt mir
alle wahrscheinlich sogar schon ein foto
gepostet wo ich dann geschrieben habe
wo ich dann geschrieben habe und dass
ich mir meine haare geschnitten habe
weil ich das lieber mag wenn ich werde
wahrscheinlich komplett anders machen
berlins videoguard azaouagh scheißegal
ich kann ich mir nicht vorstellen wie
findest du dortmund als wenn ich bin
dort mann ist eine starke mannschaft ich
bin nicht so einer der jetzt meint
dortmund hat ja echt auch viele erfolgs
band mittlerweile weil jetzt zweimal
hintereinander meister wurden sind viele
jetzt haben sie gesagt dortmund gekommen
die leiche ich mal bei facebook die sind
echt ganz cool
hardt kanister bild apple und judith
obwohl du willst mach doch mal das ich
hier relativ von apple
dann suche ich einfach mal auch apple
zielt
doch irgendwie neu ist hier auf nein
kein apple ist sie nicht irgendwo ich
muss doch noch irgendwo ein apfel haben
köpfe lacke auch nur diese blöden
goldenen ja ich sortiere bald meine
kisten meine lieben freunde konkrete
wünsche dir aber ihre kisten ach komm
ich hab kein bock zu suchen
ich nehme jetzt einfach die diamanten
die ich hoffentlich irgendwo habe er war
mal das gefühl dass mir die diamant
einfach immer weniger werden bei mir und
ich die eigentlich gar nicht verbraucht
jetzt auch keine diamanten drin hab ich
immer welche hab ich mir doch bald auch
so ein labor machen wo die japaner aloha
dadurch 890 stück das war doch noch ein
paar äpfel hier kann ich nicht irgendwie
neue ich brauche zwei äpfel kann ich die
nicht gerade mal irgendwie im clown oder
so kommen müssen noch exzellent sein
oder vom bafa zwei äpfel beste leben so
dass ich muss nur noch gleich ganz
kurzen netter und mit dieser kacke da
rausholen so sonnendeck roddick bauern
aus dieser farm sogar die zweite welt
apple habe ich jetzt noch mal eben
schnell gelöscht
schnell rein in der stadt kann man schon
mal eine neue
bla bla bla bla was macht als erstes
wenn du könig wie er ist
die stadt verändern bundesliga
lieblingsverein was ist dein
lieblingstier und dann lieblingsname
lieblingsname bei jungen finden bei
mädchen bei mädchen
das muss ja nicht sein bestimmte schwert
nehmen damit dass ursachen jobkiller
sachen oder liegt das schon irgendwie
kräftig bauen jetzt da liegt einer habe
ich 2 naja ich habe zweifel ob die beste
leben
so dann bräuchte es wäre nicht gut
kollege kleines moped hier so wohnst du
bald hoffentlich in düsseldorf magst du
mir philips oder mehr chips chips ort
das so packe dass man immer hier
rauskommen wie bis zu 1 schafft den
namen von crafter gekommen fragt lena oh
oh oh das hat schon jetzt auch er
erzählt ich habe damals das spiel
komplett gespielt habe davon etwa das
korn genommen und crafter wegen
minecraft den willst du noch umbringen
jeden dich auch nein weil sie nicht als
lautern fans die haben gegen arminia
bielefeld gewonnen und haben da eine
böse büro aktion abgezogene zweiten liga
dort fand der luca nicht so gut mag ich
mag dich nicht nein
juhu wir haben zwei weitere hart
kanister klasse kann jetzt nicht einfach
hier irgendwie recht machen
dann habe ich noch mal zwei extra herzen
das ist killer dass wir nichts geschenkt
bekommt quasi alles erschaffen diesem
ding das ist richtig cool
na ja gut wir mit 24 extra herzen und
ohne wird sich jetzt locker hingekriegt
emanuel alleine zu klatschen nicht mehr
ich stand in der ecke und er hatte
einfach tausend schläge gebraucht um
mich zu töten hätte ich einfach drauf
gegen cottbus oder tot gewesen
naja freunde
wie findet ihr jetzt das blog instanz
von staffel das haus geprüft haben ob
wohl schaffen noch zu stadt pink ging
ach du also von staffel d mark ein
vorwurf aber brocken verstehe ich nicht
was die hier alles für kaka bauen also
das verstehe ich jetzt irgendwie
wirklich nicht weil die haben auch mich
in meinem eigenen haushalt getötet weil
das hier ist ja auch nochmal hause sind
ja hier alles für meine häuser
ich habe gesagt das ganze grundstück
wird mir und das sind halt filme ich
habe sogar in dem video noch im chat
geschrieben eine vier häuser ich stehe
hier drin sogar überdacht und ich werde
einfach angegriffen also ich weiß nicht
keine ahnung
willst du mal kinder
juli eigentlich schon ich hätte schon
bock auf chinas ich weiß nicht wo finde
ich ganz cool eigentlich ich mag kinder
ich komme gut mit kindern aus außer sie
sind nerven und behindert und paris
sowie alle kinder heutzutage aber sonst
mag ich kinder jeweils nicht also ich
könnte mir nicht vorstellen später
kinder zu bekommen ich möchte auch
kinder haben
das ist falls nicht finde ich cool wieso
ihr berater es war schön zu ende dann
nämlich noch so einen komischen rat
kanister da war ich noch in miniatur
hetzen lässt kann ich mehr kräften ein
miniatur herz brauche ich ich kann ja
schon mal eigentlich alles nachkommen
nominiert uhr herzlich aluminium lässt
sich auch leicht finden
na ja gut ich komme nicht aus diesem
bild raus wegen der frage von ich komme
nicht aus diesem dieser vorstellung vor
wie ich mit dreadlocks aussehen würde
das ist richtig komisch irgendwie wenn
ich dreadlocks hätte wie das aussehen
würde das weiß nicht ich finde meine
eltern dass sich youtube mache
eigentlich gar nicht so gut
ist die ccp für oder gegen krieg kommt
auf die situation an sich die politik
auf die situation an erstmals schüler
aus mir raus gehen also eigentlich sind
wir komplett gegen krieg allerdings
haben ja schon mal erklärt wenn einer
unserer
anderen städte hier angegriffen wird nur
dann sind wir auf der stadt des
angegriffenen dann dementsprechend
anstatt geld von stadt oder angegriffen
wird sind wir auf statt geld wenn ich
nicht mehr da wird dementsprechend
entschieden aber wir werden keinen krieg
anfangen ein wohnwagen einer woche frei
wohin würdet ihr fahrrad hinfahren oder
ich wenn es auf mich bezogen ist event
blöcke geklaut wie sonst was von den
ganzen ändern wenn ihr muss man hier hin
packen so kacke tropischer so ich würde
glaube ich irgendwo in die wüste von
crystal meth kochen
hallo ich ja keinen block drunter setzen
was das da
jetzt gehts redstone fackel
jetzt vielleicht nicht kaputt machen
sollen
scheiße
etwas ausgemacht
tacke
angeht doch somit ist doch jetzt gehen
und wir sind als das müsse jetzt
trocknen ja und jetzt ist es in der cash
das gut
man drückt jetzt noch mal drauf jetzt
trocknet das steuer und jetzt darf ich
in der kiste
so jetzt haben wir noch seinen coolen
kanister es geht recht schnell
also dieser herzen machen weil sie nicht
wenn man und war eine ganze folge mit
beschäftigen aluminium zu holen ich
denke das wird relativ schnell gehen
sollte welche den kanistern sich diese
blöden kann auch habe die gar nicht
brauche so ich nehme jetzt hier mehr mir
erst mal ein steak mit und dann packe
ich nämlich gleich noch was hier in die
ss farben damit natürlich hier mal
nachbessern
der könig ist natürlich
selbstverständlich dafür verantwortlich
dass die stadt vernünftig läuft so
gepackt jetzt wieder mal ein bisschen
rein damit sie noch ein bisschen mehr
aussieht ich brauche es deckt
theoretisch noch so
so und hier noch nicht also seht der
könig der kümmert sich um seine
untertanen der papa könig gewählt ich
bin ja auch kein könig ich bin eine
repräsentative macht denn so wie in
england ich bin da wie die queen
ich baue mir deinen tollen palast hat
vorne hin vielleicht hier da man mir
dann sollen sondern tolles hier damals
ein tolles gebäuden hin wo ich dann hat
thronen werde oder einfach hier
irgendwie heute die mitarbeiter bohne
auch mit sterben hier machen die bösen
häuser ihr gatte aber ist auch gut wir
haben nichts verloren durch den tod
nichts habe alles auf soul täter
verzaubert alle sachen wieder besser
leben meine freunde ja also ich bin ja
nur repräsentative machen ich bin ein
könig mit dem kann man reden
die muss man nicht anbieten so wieder in
manch anderer stadt hier der fall war
dann kann man selbstverständlich einfach
so mit mir dann reden wenn es dann
probleme hin gibt da kann man sich dann
treffen bei einer tasse tee und dann
werde ich das selbstverständlich mich
von der gesamtsituation anpassen und
keine gar keine ausnahme machen das
nicht nur weil ihr der eigene hier der
der kev beispielsweise wenn der bisschen
böse zu mir war kann damit man darüber
reden wenn die folge ist gefallen